one of the things that was happening in
Indianapolis you heard plenty about it
we talked about it during the show where
is Tom Brady going to go and look I am
convinced that no one knows what the
hell is going on and Tom Brady loves it
now we are compelled to report on it we
are compelled to talk about it a couple
of reports that popped up last week Mike
grd of NFL media said the Giants are
interested in Tom Brady there had been
multiple reports the Colts are
interested Albert Brewer of si.com
knocks both of those down today we're
gonna have that we're gonna have this
circular firing squad of media disputing
each other's reports being caddy and
petty about who's reporting what and who
had it first that's just our reality
until Tom Brady picks a team but Colts
Colts I think makes sense more sense
than Phillip Rivers frankly for them to
go after Tom Brady but it never made
sense for the Giants to be interested in
Tom Brady they got Daniel Jones why do
you want to stunt his growth and put him
on the bench right a couple of years
just because you're infatuated with a
guy that you still don't have the
offensive line to protect it yeah that
made no sense and again I don't tom
brady's not going to a place like the
New York Giants right now like oh yeah
I've won six Super Bowls and I'm 43
years old I want to go to a rebuild yeah
right there's no way you know just
because Joe judge is there and he's from
New England it means nothing and you're
exactly right the Giants would be you
know for just lack of a better phrase
this plain old stupid if they brought
him there right now but Daniel Jones I
mean you made all the right points the
Colts won like you're right from the
football standpoint you thought like
okay well that could make sense Tom
Brady could see some things there that
he's gonna like you know the Colts won I
wonder this Mike if you know we hear
that they're not expected to pursue
Brady because they were already told at
the combine that Brady will not be
pursuing them and any stretch of the
imagination by any stretch of the
imagination you know that's where I
think of their again nothing I have a
you and I we love Indianapolis we have a
great time I just don't see Gisele
Bundchen abundant chin I can never say
her name you know John shell buns in her
bündchen I think it's technically boon
chair is not a third syllable I can say
that okay whatever the two
there's not an N in there well it's not
boon din Chindi okay well she's a
superstar and she can just go by one
name and that's Gisele and I just don't
see Tom and Gisele living in
Indianapolis Indiana I just don't I
don't think they're that that would be
their go-to type of spot again I think
Brady is gonna go somewhere where this
the team is good the team has a chance
to be in the Super Bowl this year or in
that conversation I think this is more
about money this is about yeah maybe
like you've said a lot respect like he
wants it because he doesn't get it from
Bill Belichick I think he'd love to go
somewhere and win a Super Bowl and be
like huh it wasn't bill it was me and I
think those that's the type of team he's
gonna continue to look for along with
you know I think he's trying to outdo
Michael Jordan to become that icon of
seven rings over Michael six rings and
I'm with you I love Indianapolis and I
hope the combine never leaves although I
accept the fact that it's soon yeah it
seems like Bell thinks he can make money
moving it around but it's almost like
Indianapolis defers to the combine like
it's not like there's a bunch of people
everywhere these coaches and GM's are
anywhere you would want to see them and
it's not like there's a crush of fans
going around trying to bother them like
Indianapolis just respectfully steps
back surrenders the city to the NFL and
stays out of the way there's just like a
cluster of autograph seekers when you
leave the combine each day like four or
five people that's it and I I'm
impressed by that aspect of it that it
can proceed without being impeded by you
know what could happen in one of these
other cities where there's a crush of
fans everywhere you go and it makes it
harder to get from point A to point B
but all that said I agree also I don't
see the Bradys relocating the family to
Indianapolis and you're right it's very
it's very quick to get to the point
where you're not gonna pursue Tom Brady
if you've gotten the message last week
that you're not on Tom Brady's List
which gets back to what we talked about
earlier we don't know who's on his list
no no when I hear the Dolphins say why
would he want to come here well okay
fine
but he wants to that changes everything
right yes uh as Steven Ross and Brian
Flores ah why would you want to come
here well I do
okay well we'll get a locker ready for
you so I don't know who is gonna fall
into that category we threw around some
ideas during the show but I think we
can't overlook where Tom thinks he wants
to be and how do you say no to that
whoever you are dolphins 49ers any other
team out there if he wants to play for
you and you say no and it gets out and
he does well somewhere else and you
don't you look as bad as the Texans did
in 2012 for saying no to Peyton Manning
when he wanted to play for them and they
decided to stick with Matt Schaub right
how'd that work out for the Texans yeah
that's a very real dynamic here if Tom
wants you to be interested I think that
changes your analysis dramatically yeah
I mean I think you're you're right about
that it's going to corner teams into
yeah it's gonna put teams in the corner
a little bit for all the reasons you
mentioned yeah they're enough now I
might get leaked that he wanted to be
there we didn't do it yeah he goes
somewhere else and is successful now we
get you know the backlash from our own
fans and all that but I will say this
there's gonna be a number of teams that
you know again you know a Tom Brady's
not necessarily gonna be the right thing
for that team at that moment you could
have a young team and you're trying to
build things you don't want to
necessarily have an old guy who came
from a different culture and all that
you know coming into your locker room
and shaking things up when you're trying
to mold this younger team into you know
being having their own culture and
having leaders and all that so you know
again I'm really interested to I don't
know where this goes my heart of hearts
tells me you know a team like the
Tennessee Titans would make a lot of
sense I get that because I think there's
potential there and I just feel like
there's there's probably a team out
there that we're not thinking of or
there's something going on in the back
channels that were not aware of where
Brady and his crew are trying to work
some angle and that's where I just don't
know and it gets very interesting to me
well now that the combine is over the
clock is ticking toward March 16 the
closer we get to that date without news
of a deal with the Patriots the
likely it is that he will be leaving and
I just want to say one other thing about
Brady this came up last week there was a
report and I can't remember how many
different people put this out there I
don't think it was just one but this
idea that well the reason the Patriots
and Brady's representatives didn't meet
in Indy is because they don't know
what's gonna be up with the CBA so they
don't know how the deal is gonna be
structured look there's two options they
get a new CBA or they don't it's not all
that difficult to know what the general
structure of a deal would be under
either scenario you still get together
you still make it clear that you want
the guy you still make it clear that
this is the range of the raw dollars
he's gonna make this year regardless of
how we structure it so I think that was
kind of a that was kind of a cop out PR
type of a leak aimed at making it look
not disrespectful that the Patriots
didn't get together with his agent I
think that there is a level of
disrespect there I mean he's meeting
with everybody else who's interested why
don't you just at least bring him in and
talk to him and make it clear that they
want to keep him and they look forward
to negotiating this thing once they know
what the CBA is going to be and and I
just I think that was a that was a
telling omission by the Patriots to not
get together with Don ye-yeah and what
the Patriots though and again you know
one point here Belichick is gonna tell
Brady how awesome he is and show him all
the respect in the world that times just
not here yet because he's still you know
could possibly be on the team or in the
NFL and the Patriots have become the
Patriots because they may run it like a
business no matter who's involved and I
think mr. Kraft finally gave Bill
Belichick the ride away with Brady to go
okay yep
all right I know you want them back you
don't want to give them this amount of
money or whatever it may be and Tom
feels a little spurned by so they're
gonna let him go out there and check it
I still think at the last second the
Patriots are gonna try to swoop in and
make Tom Brady and talk to him and try
to make them feel comfortable about the
Patriots once again and bring them back
I do but you know I just I wonder at
that point well Brady be too pissed off
will he be too hurt by the situation and
personally scorned by it to where he's
not gonna want
here it and he's gonna be you know you
know hell-bent on trying to get the hell
out of New England and going somewhere
else to shove it up Bill Belichick's you
know what yeah I think one thing the
Patriot Way never really accounted for
is the possibility that you're gonna
have a quarterback for twenty years yeah
and you're gonna have to convince him to
stick around for year twenty one the
other angle to that that somebody
suggested to me in Indianapolis will
Robert Kraft get involved at some point
and supersede Bill Belichick whether
it's the financial offer or whatever and
and that's the thing even if Robert
Kraft gets involved to try to keep Tom
Brady if Brandi thinks Bill Belichick
doesn't want him why stay I mean I think
Brady is looking for some indication
from Belichick that this is truly what
Belichick wants and I think Brady is
always feared that Bella cheque would
get to a point where he doesn't want him
I think he needs to see and hear
something from Belichick that lets him
know clearly and unequivocally that he
wants him to stay and without that maybe
he goes yeah no IIIi think that's very
real and I don't think you know I don't
think he's gonna get a lot of warm and
cozy words from Bill Belichick when that
time comes I mean I think bill might say
a few things showing the hey I got I
respect you and all that but this is not
gonna be like oh gosh I'm so glad you're
back Tommy let's hug and kiss and do
everything like that no I just again you
know just from my knowledge of Bill
Belichick him growing up in the Bill
Parcells school me being around that my
life with my dad and all that you know
those type of things just don't get said
with this type of regime until the
career is over and they're out of the
business aspect of it now Bill Parcells
calls my dad on you know Super Bowl
Sunday every year to say thanks and says
something like that right and shows his
appreciation a man does my dad love it I
mean he loves it to hear from Bill every
year and they talk more than that but
you know I that justice the way these
old-school NFL head coaches work they're
not gonna like you know make you if it's
not their job to make you feel
appreciated and great all the time
they're doing their job because they
think oh it pissed off Tom Brady or you
know and the Tom Brady with an edge
about them is a better football player
and that's better for our team not
necessarily better for our personal
relationship there's always that
concerning guys getting complacent guys
gonna get soft guys aren't gonna produce
and that that distance that withholding
of emotion in the minds of some of the
old school coaches is the way to get
maximum production others would say that
if you go ahead and show the emotion and
show the appreciation maybe you get even
greater dedication during the existence
of the career
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports